alright
i like to start with a small imagination
exercise
imagine you're sitting at this table
facing me right now
now i'm gonna ask you to push one of
these cards towards me
so please genuinely imagine yourself
pushing one of these cards towards me
okay so take the number matching the
card you pushed and remember it's it's
important for later
now i'm going to flip through this deck
of cards and ask you to choose the cards
that you will see in the neck
are you ready
all right now that you have your card in
mind
add the value of your cards to your
previous number
for example if you chose the six of club
at six
if it's an ace add one and take 11 for
any picture cards have you got your
final number in mind
perfect so please take the item matching
your final number
now here's what's funny they're going to
be a lot of people watching this video
and you all have different quirks with
different preferences
and yet the vast majority of you
right now is thinking about a kiwi or
if you're left-handed probably a corn on
the cob
yes i just tricked you and i used your
psychological biases to influence
both of your decisions i work in the
magic lab
at goldsmiths university of london which
is not only a place where we make
assistance furnish
but where we use magic tricks to study
psychological processes
such as attention perception deception
and free will i am fascinated by the
subtle factors that influence our
choices
and how understanding our flows can give
us back some power
tricks provide a powerful tool to
investigate this
and our experiments have shown that
first we humans tend to go for
the easiest decisions with the card
trick i did
most people tend to choose the card that
i want them to choose
because i'm presenting it a bit longer
than the others
and it becomes the easiest option for
your brain
in our case the majority of you probably
chose the ten of hearts
right and a lot of other tricks are
based on this principle of easy decision
because magicians are very aware that
our brain
not to say we tends to be a bit lazy
the exercise we did with the four cards
is also a good example of this
it's based on another trick i
investigated where i asked participants
to physically push one of the four cards
towards me
we found that around 60 of people choose
the third card from the left
and if they were left-handed they
typically chose the second card from the
left
this is based on the easy option
principle again
because the card that most people choose
is the most easily reached by the
dominant hands
so i knew that most of you would end up
with
one of these two numbers and this
allowed me to estimate
the two most probable things you would
end up with
but this is not just about magic
it's also about how we are influenced in
our day-to-day lives
you know stories and politicians
play with your mind as well all the time
because they also know that we tend to
choose and like
what's easily grabbed or seen for
instance
when you're in a store choosing a bottle
of wine or a bag of rice among
many lined up on multiple shelves your
first instinct
is to look only at the ones that are on
the shelves in front of your eyes
right it's easier and requires less
effort
did you know that many brands actually
negotiate to be at our level on grocery
store shelves because of that easy
option principle
and this is a tactic that many
politicians use
when information is right in front of
our eyes on social media
it's easily accessible and it absolutely
affects our voting behaviors
political outcomes such as the brexit
referendum or the american election in
were heavily influenced by targeted
advertising
making some information which was not
necessarily truthful
disproportionately easily accessible and
visible to specific audiences
to influence their votes but
here is the good news some simple
factors
have an impact on how influenceable we
are
in an experiment using the trick with
the four cards
we found that explicitly informing
participants that they have a choice
can actually lead them to make more
deliberate decisions
as opposed to behaving in the way we are
trying to make them behave
in other words i either simply ask
participants to
push one of the cards or i said
choose a card and then push it and when
asked to choose a card
the percentage of people who impulsively
chose the most reachable one
dropped from 60 to 35
so it seems that when we are reminded
that
we have control over our choices and
know that our actions matters
as opposed to acting without thinking we
can actually make more personal
decisions
and are less easily influenced let me
show you another trick
invented by british mentalist theron
brown to make my points
this one uses what's called priming in
psychology
priming happens when exposure to
something
influences your thoughts and behavior
later on without you being aware that
the first thing
is guiding you to a certain extent the
trick is usually done
in a more intimate context where i would
be directly facing you but
we'll give it a try together just focus
on me
as best as you can but do not
let me influence your choice i'm gonna
try and mentally transmit the identity
of your playing card i'm thinking of
are you ready okay so first make the
color bright and vivid
imagine a screen in your mind and on the
screen the little numbers low down in
the corners of the cards
and then in the top of the cards and
then the things in the middle
in the center of the cards the boom boom
boom the suits
did you get it okay
so i'm gonna bet that the majority of
you thought about
the three of diamonds but chose another
card
right as you might have noticed i
heavily tried to influence your choice
with my gestures while giving you the
instructions
by studying this trick we found that
around 18 percent of people choose the
three of diamonds
and nearly 40 percent choose the three
of any suits
while being completely oblivious of the
fact i was manipulating them
so what happened here
because you were aware that i was trying
to influence your choice
you probably paid more attention to what
i want to swing
and this led the majority of you to
choose more consciously
than our participants who have no
information about who i am
what i'm studying or what i'm trying to
do with their minds
so the thing is in
all of our experiments we managed to
heavily influence people's car choices
while they report feeling completely
free and in control of their choice
and this lack of self-awareness makes
politicians companies
and other people's influence all the
more powerful
because we might think we are in control
of our choice and beliefs
when we are not politically or
in our consumer behaviors if we don't
pay attention
misleading content or shall we adds can
just trick our minds
what if in our day-to-day lives
we would stop more often and consciously
choose before acting on this impulsive
reactive beast inside of us
we can actually act more consciously if
we keep in mind that we have the
capacity to be influenced
thank you